[Music]
has it sunk in that you're a rock star
no uh but it's soaking in a little more
I'm not working with the ceremony went
pink there and you had Brandi Carlile
supporting you what was it like getting
their support well I love them and I I
just think they're all great all those
gals that were on the show that not Pat
Benatar and Linux and and then of course
Brandy and pink and all the others that
were there it was just great to be in
that house with all those great talented
people and for them to accept me and
kind of make me feel welcome like I was
deserved none of it whether I am or not
I figure if I'm gonna be in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame
I'm gonna have to earn it
[Applause]
my husband had always told me I should
do a rock album because he is a huge I
mean heavy metal Rock and roller and so
I thought well maybe I will someday but
then when they wanted to end up me into
the Hall of Fame and I didn't think I
deserved it then when they put me in
anyway I thought well I'm going to not
waste this time and to do a real rock
and roll album a true rock and roll not
country at all with rock musicians rock
singers everything you know I wrote with
Kent Wells who actually produced the
album we wrote A Few Originals together
and then I wrote some on my own so we're
going to have some classic singers and
some classic songs and some originals
and I'm calling it rockstar I thought
why not of course because I'm a rock
star though you are a rock star now
but I'm gonna I'm gonna take advantage
of of the timing we'll send your thanks
to Dolly's other half Carl Dean for her
upcoming rock album while Carl chooses
to stay out of the spotlight the two
have been married since May 30th 19 66
is there any artist that Carl is
extremely excited that you are working
with well he loves all the songs that I
haven't told him yet who I'll go into
perfectly have on it I don't even know
myself who all is going to be on it but
he'll love it I'm doing so many of his
favorite songs on the album so I'll play
it to him when it's all done I'm sure
people ask you this all the time but is
there a staple answer for how you guys
have lasted so long 56 years well we
love each other we respect each other we
both have a warped sense of humor and I
think humor honestly I think that is one
of the best things when you're married
like that because even when you have a
problem if you have a great sense of
humor rather than going that way and you
know if you say something you can't take
back that's gonna so we we usually have
some crazy way of getting out of it but
I like him and people say how did it
last so long I say I stay gone
there's a lot to be said about that we
misses each other's face all the time
and we don't he's not in the business so
we have different interests but yet we
have the things we love to do together
so it was meant to be I think he was the
one I was supposed to have and and vice
versa is there any artists right now
that you are very impressed by that you
feel are really forging their own path
Brandi Carlile I think it's great she's
like me she kind of crosses all bridges
she's just such a great writer such a
great gal such a beautiful singer too so
I'm very impressed with what she's doing
she's a great producer so she's very uh
very talented Talon is something dolly
is familiar with releasing Dolly Parton
diamonds and rhinestones the greatest
hits collection you just released your
greatest hits album that's exciting well
I've had several Greatest Hits yeah this
one is the ultra because it's got a lot
of the big songs but a lot of new songs
a lot of stuff that people have not
heard before things that they say were
held in the can meaning all the chefs
stuff you record yeah and then also
putting things like Duets like with
Kenny and a lot of things that that are
really from other albums and stuff so
it's a really a good album I'm proud of
that of course one song featured on the
album is Dolly's 1980s hits nine to five